joe biden made a rare appearance tonight
to answer
softball questions walk us through what
you would do differently
and assuming it actually by then will be
worse i don't know how bad it's going to
be it's going to just be worse because
he's doing nothing to deal with what he
said was going to go away
it's going to get worse i speak with
docs every
three times a week sometimes four times
a week for an hour and 15 minutes
they they predict among them that
they're going to be over 200 000 dead by
the time we get to election day
they predict that this is just going to
get worse and worse
translation biden says trump bad on
kovid
virus bad so trump plus virus
is worse if i'm fortunate enough to be
elected president
where we're going to have to take
significant action to do a number of
things
one you need more testing you need to be
able to test and trace
you need to be in a position where
you're able to insist that everyone
wear masks everyone's socially distanced
that
businesses do not open if they cannot do
that we need to keep people on their
feet
we need to make sure health insurance as
we have health insurance as well as
making sure
no one has to pay for contracting covert
and or being treated for covid
well how many of you think that's
realistic
no one ever has to pay for anything
is he even aware that we've done more
testing than any nation on earth as of
today
we've done 48.6 million
covid tests in the united states and
there's no indication at all that biden
could do any more any faster at least we
haven't seen the evidence of that
so that's all bunk so what's left
rolling shutdowns or a complete national
shutdown until the virus magically
disappears
we opened up too soon we didn't have the
virus totally under control
you have to just shut down for now
i think that that is our only way out if
you leap frog
over different phases you increase the
risk
that you're going to have the kind of
resurgences that we're seeing
how much worse does it have to get in
los angeles before
you feel compelled to issue another
stay-at-home order
sure well i think we're on the brink of
that
i said this last week i fully expect
that by like october
all blue states in the united states
will be either shut down or on the way
to shut down
and of course we've tried shutting down
all across america and the virus is
obviously still there
meanwhile we lost millions and millions
of jobs
now sweden didn't take the heavy-handed
approach and they're basically through
the worst of it
now let's go on to tracing and tracking
this means among other things that the
government
forces you to download an app on your
phone that keeps you monitored
if you test positive now hundreds of
thousands of paid trackers it's kind of
like a new tsa for the virus that
will roam around the country to keep us
safe you know
to that i say why doesn't new york and
california
show us how great their tracing and
tracking is what's stopping them
from showing everyone how well it works
and finally on the math question biden
sounds like he would issue some sort of
i guess
federal rule mandating masks for the
foreseeable future forever for all we
know
maybe everywhere except when you're in
your own home with your family
now it's hard to see any of that's
constitutional and as we told you last
week the science on cloth masks
is very murky and that's putting it
charitably nevertheless president trump
is embracing them
and they may make some people feel
better and more patriotic so that's fine
but let's get real here if there were a
magic democrat solution to the virus
governors gavin newsom in california
gretchen whitmer and michigan
would have been bragging about it by now
andrew cuomo's nursing homes wouldn't
have become
killing fields rather than acknowledging
that there are real trade-offs in
fighting the virus
the left is living in la la land because
they act like shutting down
and doing it again and again and again
that has zero consequences
throwing people onto the unemployment
rolls however we know
has major consequences many of the small
businesses are barely holding on as it
is
and now they're having the rug out
pulled out from underneath them again
pain comes in many forms we all know
that
but instead of recognize that
recognizing that this is a tragedy
it's caused by china and one that
neither republican
or democrat could easily solve democrats
and their media
pals are playing election year politics
i guess it's to be expected
but wouldn't it be nice every now and
then
if good news or even good trends were
embraced by both parties
now look at this graph deaths and
hospitalizations
look like they've peaked in arizona
they're going down let's hope they keep
doing that that's according to the
arizona republic icu bed
and er visits by suspected and confirmed
covet cases have begun to drop
ventilator use is also decreasing the
death toll in texas
peaked at 174 last week and has been
trickling down
since then we'll look for the same trend
in florida
later this week but the reason we can't
have a serious grown-up conversation
about this is because
every time some county in some state
has an uptick in some infections the
press screams
it's all trump's fault you see you know
we opened up too fast
i'm here tonight to tell you that's
childish and it's
stupid same with promising that
lockdowns won't cost
our country dearly or pretending we can
keep
borrowing and printing money to cover
all non-essential salaries
until the pandemic is gone that's called
mailbox money
try hiring someone in a restaurant today
we need to carefully examine
trade-offs of every move we make in
response to this virus
think about it doctors focus primarily
on one thing
it's a medical side that's what they're
trained to do but it's the president's
job
to focus on the whole country our
elderly
are now suffering alone our children
are suffering by staying at home parents
are worried about how they can
possibly manage it all and employers are
beginning to do the math and the numbers
are ugly and of course americans mostly
the elderly are compromised
are still tragically succumbing to the
virus
but here as we've shown you the deaths
have been steadily declining since their
peak in march
trump's approach has been wise he
couldn't lose the
entire u.s economy by mandating a
lockdown of 330 million americans that
would have been ridiculous would have
been
abusive plus as we saw in may the
democrats were fine with protesters who
gathered by the thousands
some of whom by the way are still
smashing up the place in portland oregon
those are still being excused by the
left and we're being criticized as i
mentioned to hannity for covering them
there are real problems in portland but
it is made up on fox news like it's this
raging fire out of control and that is a
gross exaggeration
it just is it's a gross exaggeration
so the democrats are offering free
lockdowns
and an exemption from the lockdowns to
anyone who agrees with them their agenda
now you can see why that offer kind of
would be appealing to folks who don't
realize that lockdowns
actually carry an enormous cost that
can't be made up with
new welfare programs and i'm talking
human costs more lives
other illnesses not attended to
in reality we need a serious and we need
a balanced approach
to lower the harm caused by the virus
while doing the best we can
to protect the economy our families
our kids and our small businesses so
governors in places like texas and
florida
they've tried this more nuanced approach
and it's not going to be perfect nothing
is
but they have been more successful than
their counterparts
in new york and california by a long
shot
but it's hard to defend and explain
nuance sometimes isn't it
and much easier to scream we need a
national plan
so the swing voters well they're turning
against the gop in some cases because
the white house has been telling them
three things
they don't want to hear number one over
time
you can only become prosperous by
working for it not by borrowing money or
printing it
number two you can't cure a virus by
shutting down your economy
and hiding from it and number three
no matter how much sympathy you have for
young people
it's a mistake to encourage riots
and looting and the destruction of
property
now these are things that a lot of
voters may not want to hear now
and repeating them may hurt the gop in
the short run
but they're all true and they will be
true no matter what the swing voters may
want
and that's the angle